le 8 mars c'est surtout la journée pour
ne pas oublier ne pas oublier que
l'égalité réelle n'est pas encore au
rendez-vous ne pas oublier qu'il y a 16%
d'écart entre les salaires ne pas
oublier que l'égalité réelle c'est la
transformation des mentalités alors les
situations d'inégalités finalement
elles sont presque quotidiennes il y en
a évidemment dans le monde politique
mais il y en a dans la vie de tous les
jours et il y a deux manières de voir
les choses les accepter ne rien dire
faire comme si c'était pas grave ou au
contraire les dénoncer et les combattre
l'écart de salaire entre les hommes et
les femmes est aujourd'hui de 16%
c'était évidemment beaucoup trop mais ça
a diminué ces dernières années on a
travaillé sur un index pour l'égalité
entre les rémunérations des hommes et
les femmes c'est-à-dire les manières la
manière d'évaluer une entreprise qui
pratique de l'inégalité entre les
salaires aujourd'hui ne recrutent pas et
ne recrutera plus à l'avenir désormais
les entreprises et organisations qui ne
se conformeraient pas à cette index
égalité professionnelle ne pourrait pas
avoir accès au marché public l'égalité
réelle entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est l'égalité des congés parentaux
c'est l'égalité dans les salaires c'est
l'égalité dans l'éducation c'est
l'égalité demain dans la capacité à se
projeter c'est la lutte contre
l'autocensure c'est l'égalité face à la
précarité on a renforcé la présence des
femmes dans les comités de direction
mais on constate encore aujourd'hui
finalement qu'on a des métiers dits
féminins qui sont encore finalement
moins bien payés que l'équivalent de
métier d'immasculin le Ségur de la santé
qui a augmenté les professionnels de
santé de 183 euros par mois or on le
sait dans le secteur de la santé mais
aussi dans le médico-social ce sont
majoritairement des femmes l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes ce n'est
pas une journée ce n'est pas le 8 mars
c'est que je suis vivement 8 mars n'est
qu'un rendez-vous en réalité c'est tous
les jours et pour cela on a besoin de
chacun d'entre vous tous les jours à
chaque moment à chaque instant en tout
lieu le combat pour les droits des
femmes ne s'arrêtent pas et ne se résume
sûrement pas au 8 mars c'est un combat
que nous menons avec François Bayrou au
sein du Mouvement Démocrate en France
pour l'égalité professionnelle pour
l'accès à toutes nos droits mais
également partout dans le monde en Iran
en Afghanistan en Ukraine les femmes se
battent pour leur liberté et nous sommes
et resterons au Mouvement Démocrate à
leur côté